well just recently Hillary Clinton said
that Brett Kavanaugh could not be
allowed on the Supreme Court we had to
believe his accuser she said even
without evidence the Clinton turns out
to be one of the most self-aware
politicians in this country that's a
high bar so it wasn't too surprising
that on Sunday she backtracked from this
position she told CBS that her own
husband
had no obligation to resign over the
Monica Lewinsky scandal some today have
said he should have stepped down in
retrospect do you think bill should have
resigned in the wake of the Monica
Lewinsky scandal
it wasn't an abuse of power no no there
are people who look at the incidents of
the 90s and they say a President of the
United States cannot have a consensual
relationship with an intern the power
imbalances too was an adult but let me
ask you this where's the investigation
of the current incumbent well even the
ladies of the view are not buying this
line of argument instead they ripped
Hillary Clinton believe it or not for
her evasive interview tactics here's a
selection what she just did is exactly
what the Republicans do right they
change the subject so that's why we
never get anywhere in the discourse yo
you know you a bad argument when your
immediate response is well they were
worse
call it out for being wrong and from
being bad for all those years I just
don't think she can have a bit both ways
claims that Hillary tried to intimidate
or silenced Cathleen Wiley claims the
Clintons tried to intimidate her and
they're not telling the truth she called
model Monica Lewinsky a narcissistic
loony tune Jennifer flowers some failed
cabaret singer Democrats have got to
move on from the Clintons Camille Polly
is an author one of the country's best
own cultural critics she has written
extensively about Hillary Clinton for
more than 20 years among many other
topics her latest book is titled
provocations and Camille Palio joins us
tonight we're honored to have you thank
you very much for coming on so Thank You
Tucker yeah Hillary Clinton is mentioned
actually quite a bit in this book yeah
for ask you broader questions about
what's happening in this country what's
your reaction to her role in the the
kind of meet to movement of right now
well it's very ambiguous I don't I think
that her history has been hypocritical I
was the only Democrat feminist to call
for Bill Clinton's resignate
and I had voted for him twice and don't
regret it but it was a scandal that they
the squalor that he introduced into the
people's house this all this was
happening the servicing of him by by an
intern in the White House offices yes no
it's it's a very good point in a good
reminder so what as you as someone who's
written about sex and gender roles in
our society for so long for many decades
what do you make of the convulsion we're
going through particularly of the me2
movement well it's it's great that
attention is being paid to the women's
being women being abused died in 1986 I
was lobbying for moderate sexual
harassment guidelines at my university
in Philadelphia but I think we've gone a
bit too far here I think that you know
fun fundamental civil rights involving
the presumption of innocence so they
have to be considered so what I'm I what
I espouse as a feminist is that women
themselves must take charge of their own
interactions with men they must signal
at the time that something is
unacceptable that's waiting 10 years 20
years 30 years is this is not a not only
not American it's Stalinist but women
were told again and again by people who
claim to empower women are themselves
powerless and can't they can't say
anything because their show okay no
working-class women yes maybe so
dependent upon a job that they cannot
protest but there as I have written
there's no excuse for well-educated
upper middle class professional women to
let offenses to their dignity go by you
must make draw the line when it happens
it's absurd that you feel too powerless
and you can't complain these people that
women who say that are simply putting
the career advantage over the larger
question of feminist issues in the
protection of women you've written so
much about let me just be blunt about
sex for all these years what do you make
of seeing your I guess former allies on
the Left strike an almost evangelical or
Puritan
position on these questions the kind of
Bluenose outrage at sensual pleasure at
personal happiness telling you that you
know you're not allowed to do this or do
that I mean what do you make of this
well there has been a split within
feminism since second wave feminism was
born in the late 1960s the media has
have been extremely lazy and not
pursuing this I belong to the pro-sex
Pro pop culture wing of feminism I favor
the legalization of prostitution I have
defended pornography I admire strip
clubs etc etc so there's all there has
been this argument for a very long time
my my branch one in the 90s thanks to
Madonna suddenly bursting on the scene
but the Madonna has faded in lost all
sense of her own trajectory and I am
astonished after the victory of the
pro-sex wing that we're back to feminist
Puritanism again of the Andrea Dworkin
kind we're talking about mental
imbalance that we're talking about
hysteria that has nothing whatever to do
with women's rights these are neurotics
okay who are who are talking about
hatred of men who are poisoning the
culture making more difficult for young
women to reconcile with young men you
may not agree with come up kima Polly if
you're watching the show but trust me
one of the more interesting people out
there an engaging writer and this is her
new book provocations and they do indeed
provoke prima Polly it's great to see
you tonight thank you for that Thank You
Tucker